so good morning everybody
hope you're having a fabulous friday so
far whether you're just getting started
or coming to the end of your friday
welcome to ask doc live
just let everybody in here in just a
minute we will be getting started
i love all your smiling faces
that's fabulous
awesome awesome and i see we have people
from all
around the world i love it love it
and um just so everybody knows this is a
program that you can share with other
people and
invite other people to so if you are um
involved with youngevity and on this
crusade with dr
wallach um this is a
resource made available to you
we always want to emphasize
that if somebody shared this program
with you
get back with the person that shared
this program
with you so we do have a quality that's
standing by
but that is only for people who have
never been
introduced to youngevity by somebody
specific
or a friend or a loved one so
please only use our call-in number
um for
no contact whatsoever with anybody
within your longevity or a friend that
recommend this program to you
so this is the askdoc live
program my name is rebecca kozak and i
will be your host for the next two hours
i am honored to be joined by my co-hosts
who are jonty mccollier
who is running all the technical stuff
in the back end and a beautiful russell
and
sanchez who's here to help guide the
chat and provide information in the chat
and also nasima will be here with us
here shortly
um and if you have
questions for dr wallach please
raise your hand make sure you're ready
to turn your camera on
he loves to see your smiling faces that
helps give him
a kind of a visual not kinda
it gives him a visual that he can see a
lot of what is going
on in addition to the information that
you're sharing with him about
health concerns for yourself or your
loved one
so please raise your hand if you're not
familiar with how to
raise your hand in the zoom menu
you've got two options you can click on
participants and under the participants
there are three dots click on the three
dots and you'll see the raise hand
option also depending on the version of
zoom that you have
in that menu bar are reactions
with those reactions one of those
options
is raised pan so i want everybody to
know how to raise their hand
and how to uh put comments
in the chat now whenever you are putting
comments in the chat
you can hold this shift key down to hit
enter
and it puts information on the next line
without sending it to the chat so we can
keep all your information together
please include age weight and height
in addition to your main concern
and any other health concerns that are
going on whether it's a diagnosis
that all all that information is helpful
all right
so i have to read this
lovely disclaimer that the content of
this program
is to provide nutritional education
information only this program is not
meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the fda
does require
us to let you know that our products are
not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases but any
testimonials that are shared
on this program are real life results
using the products
mentioned and recommended by dr joel
wallick
as empowered individuals you do
have options the purpose of this
program is to share natural options that
are available through supplementation
and we are honored to have one of the
founding fathers of
epigenetics here to guide us
with the best options to obtain and
maintain
optimal health dr joel wallick
welcome to ask doc live well thank you
so much for the kind introduction
rebecca and welcome to the whole team
uh just always appreciate uh the
mornings here with you guys and gals
um and of course we want to talk about
uh longevity today
um all vertebrates you know have a
uh optimal longevity including human
beings
uh there's no reason why human beings
can't live well well
be 150 beyond 150 but you got to work
at it your car can go over 300 000 miles
but if you put
dirt from texas in the car instead of
oil now they're bound to be some oil in
it that's dirt from texas
you're not going to get 300 000 miles
you cut the fan belt
because you don't like to hear that
noise okay you're not going to go 300
000 miles um you take out the air filter
and let dirt get into your carburetor
you're not going to go 300 000 miles
if you use kerosene instead of gasoline
you're not going to go very far okay
unless you have a kind of a diesel
kerosene using
engine and so you really have to do all
the right stuff
for yourself if you want to maximize
your lifespan in modern times
uh the oldest super centenarian some
people who live beyond 110
was gene calment from france and she
died in 1997
and 122 years 164 days
okay and she was the oldest one in the
last
century then right now the oldest living
person
in the world is a japanese woman by the
name of kane tanaka
okay and she's 118 well documented
and then um there was a i shouldn't say
there was there is a
french nun okay her birth name was
lucille
randall arandan i guess is randon
um then when she became a catholic nun
in in
france they changed her name to sister
andrea
okay when she was 116 years of age she
actually got cove at 19
and her caregivers all died from it but
she lived
okay she's currently 117 years old
and she lives in the pyrenees mountains
in france which is near
lourdes of france where all these highly
mineralized waters are
okay so you begin to start seeing a
pattern here the people who
um in the blue zones there's five blue
zones put together
by um daniel buettner
who was an exercise guru and he believed
that these people
in the blue zones and they were called
blue zones because he took a blue marker
and draw
drew a circle around on the map where he
looked at places where people lived a
long time
so he called them blue zones nothing
scientific just a marker
but he said all these people in these
five blue zones live a long time because
they're happy
he missed it by a thousand miles no
they're happy because they've lived a
long time
without any kind of really severe
disabilities and pain and all that kind
of stuff
and the reason is of course their diet
they live on
islands or peninsulas that have volcanic
ash and
access to algae and sea seaweed and that
kind of stuff
except for the peop the fifth blue zone
uh was in loma linda california the
seventh-day adventists but they're very
religious people and they're very very
tight on what they avoid and what they
eat and how and they supplement their
big big big on supplements
and so they're part of the blue zones
and then let's see here
i think that covers that sort of stuff
and so you have to appreciate um right
now
with all this pandemic and stuff going
on there's other pieces you have to
throw in
right um i've been for 25 years using
our colloidal silver
put two droppers full under my tongue 30
minutes for each meal and two droppers
fall under my tongue 30 minutes for a
bedtime been doing that for 25 years
and it kills all bugs viruses bacteria
fungus and yeast and so forth
and doesn't have any negative effects on
the person
i also have hand sanitizer which you
should use
distance yourself and wear your mask all
that kind of stuff
but you also have to take your 90
essential nutrients because all living
tissue
has a lifespan
and you know it has to be replaced when
it dies naturally
and so you need raw materials to give
your stem cells what it needs to make a
new liver cell a new kidney cell a new
heart cell a new lung cell a new
muscle cell a new bone cell a new tendon
cell new cartilage cell
a new brain cell a new eye cell all
these things die
on a daily minute-by-minute basis and
they need replacing
and if you don't take in the nutrients
necessary for your stem cells to replace
the ones that are dying naturally
you get what doctors call you have an
autoimmune disease your body's attacking
itself
shouldn't be taking some vitamins
minerals nah just eat well you get
everything you need any doctor who says
that should be put in jail as a serial
killer
okay particularly if they're telling eat
wheat serial killer hello
okay a double meaning there um
so this this is very very important when
you look for instance
who had the worst time during the
spanish flu it was people from india
in six months time they had 20 million
people died uh they didn't have enough
wood to
cremate everybody so they're just
throwing the bodies in the rivers and
the bodies
began to dam up the rivers 20 million in
six months
and these bodies were damning up the
rivers and creating flooding and all
kinds of negative stuff in india
they didn't really learn anything from
them right now the same thing is
happening in india
they're dying at a rate of 3449 per day
right now in india they have 230 168
dead
they have 21 million 664
900 infections and the new infections
are going up at 360
960 per day so that
every three days they're getting a new
million infections now they were
banging along at 16 million infections
for about six months you know adding 50
here that
wasn't a big deal but boy let me tell
you
they really got hit um because you know
they said well you're
you know we got two percent vaccinated
everybody can run around do what they
want
and they weren't taking any vitamins and
minerals they weren't doing this
and the other and so now um they've got
960 to
400 000 new infections every day and so
every three days you're getting 1.2
million new infections and that's why
they went from 16 million
um like five six weeks ago
to 21 million now okay 21 million 664.
so there's many many reasons why you
need to take your 90 ascension nutrients
give your
your bone marrow which is your immune
system what it needs to
react to let's say you get the
vaccinations that's everybody's choice
you're going to get the vaccination out
we have to appreciate that vaccines do
not kill viruses bacteria fungus and
yeast they just alert your body to bad
dna and rna that's in the viruses
bacterial fungus and use when the bug
comes along everybody says oh
there's some of those bad guys then it
released white blood cells and
stem cells release things like
antibodies rebellious cells and
platelets go kill and eat the viruses
and prevent you from bleeding to death
during the battle
against the viruses and bacteria but
if you're eating gluten okay you cannot
absorb because the villian intestines
are dead
so you're down to two percent absorption
and if you're not supplementing two
percent and nothing's not very much
and so this is why people who are
getting vaccinated or dying
like flies in india and they're saying
oh it's a new variant
no it's just that the the body cannot
kill anything if it doesn't have the
machinery to get
antibodies and white blood cells to go
kill it so
90 essential nutrients um don't forget
you want to take some extra stuff for
your bone marrow
msm vitamin d3 i like the
glucogel don't forget our fucoid z which
is
more of the algae and seaweed and stuff
like that
again these weird trace minerals that
are necessary for your bone marrow to
make what they're supposed to make
and also we have another one in addition
to fucoid z
we do have a liquid form of that called
z radical so
i don't take the liquid maybe on the
airplanes it's too heavy they won't let
me take out the airplanes
but i do when i'm at home like on the
weekends i'll use the z
radical and during the week and i'm in a
hurry i'll use a fucoid z but i also
take and i've been doing this for like
20 years
the uh ocean's gold so i'm getting the
the
the trace minerals from both oceans okay
and so these are the sort of things i'm
82 years old
and it's one of those things where
people say look you've got to be kidding
you're not 82 yeah i am
okay now how now here's here's a trick
question
okay are you ready for this rebecca
trick question
i'm warning you it's a trick question
i'm ready when you're
okay when you're born you know you're
born
how old are you when you're born i was
10 months
okay nine to ten months you get an a
plus okay
so birth date plus three months you're
already a year old
so when your birth date a year
okay you go a year now you're already
not you're not one years old you're
already two years old
when your first birthday comes along
because the birth date is not how old
you are
you have to um
start your your aging from the moment
the sperm fertilizes the egg and you
you've been conceived okay and so when
you're born you're you're
something like nine to ten months old
and it's one of those things where
um most women do not take prenatal
vitamins well you know
i'm not sexually active yeah but you're
in the birth you know you're in the
birth uh
years and um you have to go back to the
old days in the old bible
in the old bible in the old testament
there's places in there they say
men should wear men's clothes and women
should wear women's clothes
now why would they have that in the old
testament because they had transgenders
back then
okay they had gender issues back then
um what about joan of arc one of the
greatest warriors of all time
uh uh was she transgender probably
okay because you know somebody who's a
milkmaid and raising kids
isn't gonna go out with a sword and kill
a bunch of enemies okay so
these things are timeless and so
if you want to have a perfect pregnancy
even though you don't plan on a
pregnancy
you better be taking vitamins and
minerals and stay away from all the bad
stuff to maximize absorption
for a minimum of six months
six years 30 years before you get
pregnant
don't be taking a prenatal vitamin you
know i missed two periods i went and got
you know that little test strip
from the pharmacy and i'm pregnant i've
already missed two periods uh-oh
you know that embryo can be in deep
trouble here um the
uh hypothalamus in your brain the part
of the brain
that tells you okay you're gonna chase
girls or you're gonna chase boys
or if it's confused because it was
underdeveloped because your mom didn't
get everything she needed to develop
your hypothalamus
okay you could become a transgender you
could become a gay man you could become
a lesbian woman you could become a
bisexual you could become an asexual you
know there's so many people
who are asexual both males and females
they're not interested in sex at all
okay because that part of their brain is
not functioning because it's
underdeveloped
in that early pregnancy when they went
from a flat disc into a tube
okay so this is very important stuff
and if you want to you know give a young
couple who are dating something nice
give them the 90 cents of nutrients okay
get them on auto ship
and make sure they're taking them and so
we can eliminate a lot of this confusion
and so forth and again it's nothing new
because it was in it's in the old bible
they had those problems and issues back
then
because the cause of those issues back
then are the same cause of those issues
now okay and so
um it's one of those things where we
have to be you know a little ahead of
the game here
um there are things you can do and
that's of course we have of course
the um ultrasounds and things like that
you can do testings of embryos and
things and i really really really feel
sorry for couples who have embryos with
you know really severe issues and they
have to make a choice are we going to
abort this
embryo with all these severe issues are
we going to raise this baby
and so on and you can eliminate that
crises
and by taking the 90 cent of nutrients
and staying away from bad foods maximize
absorption
you'll add 25 to 50 healthful years to
your life
why not die at 122 years 164 days like
gene calmed
okay why not diet like methuselah
okay um and you're talking about in the
days of moses 300 years of age that kind
of stuff
but you're going to have to work at it
it's got to be a priority
uh you just can't be flippant about
those things because your your
your body as it's farming inside the mom
you can prevent cleft palates but if the
baby's burning the cleft palate and you
do surgery and fix it
same thing with heart defects okay if
everything's perfect
that you'll be born with a perfectly
normal heart but
if you're born with a heart defects if
it's severe enough okay they may
put this newborn baby on a heart
transplant list right away
okay uh and so you can avoid all this
stuff
and add 25 to 50 health years your life
just by you know doing things correctly
and people say well my doctor says
you're going to get all the stuff this
is an aging thing no
you see people um with gray hair
they're 12 years old like michael
jackson okay
vitiligo they're black kids and they
have snow white skin like michael
jackson
okay or they have you know maybe a
middle-aged black person they got little
spotty vitiligo
all over their body on their face and
everything is sort of disconcerting you
know what's happening to you
i don't know i'm just kind of losing my
pigment well that's because
um it's not an aging thing it's not an
autoimmune thing it's a nutritional
deficiency thing
and the same nutritional deficiency that
causes a vitiligo
okay which michael jackson had and
causes gray hair which michael jackson
had
also causes ruptured aneurysms in the
brain and art and pulmonary artery and
you die suddenly from
they're all caused by the same
deficiency and so
gray hair varicose veins and hemorrhoids
which is
which is varicose veins in a funny place
okay your body's telling you that's your
red warning lights
hey pay attention here i'm telling you
you're gonna die of a ruptured aneurysm
if you don't deal with this
you go to the doctor he says well you
gotta expect this you're 60 years old
as an agent no that doctor should have
his license taken away from
okay um let's see here
i think uh we've covered the main things
here
uh what's going on oh one other thing
um i did compare because i did a a
zoom last night in the philippines which
i do like every other thursday
and i was just checking because we were
talking about this aging thing
the average uh lifespan the life
expectancy of somebody from the
philippines is 71
years of age they have 100 million
population
in vietnam they have 97 million
population pretty close
their average lifespan is 76 they live
five years longer
okay than the filipinos well why is that
well vietnam
and vietnam they have maintained their
integrity
as an asian country and they live on
maize corn
rice sweet potatoes beans squash and
seaweed
whereas the filipinos they've had so
many armies in there
okay for a hundred years okay
well guess what um they got
spanish french americans and
and all other restaurants and places
um schools and things where they they
eat
they tilt the dietary menu towards the
western cuisine because that's where all
the money is coming from from tourists
and
and the military they want all these
military people and
i spent a lot of time in the philippines
when i was in the air force and so
they they tilt the diets in the
restaurants
and schools and um hotels and things
like that
towards the western cuisine okay
and so that's why um the people in the
philippines only live on an average of
71 and the people in vietnam lose an
average of 76.
okay um can i add something real quick
doctor
yeah yeah i was having a conversation
this week with with a young man 31 years
old
um who told me he was in very good
health
he but he well he didn't he didn't
put the butt in there um was on a statin
was on a blood pressure pill and had
hemorrhoids
and my my you know
i had to um he's got a deficiency my
words
yes he's got a definition sign with my
words and ask
so what part of that
of what you just described to me is very
good health
yeah exactly so i mean
these conditions dr wallach that you had
mentioned
you know 61 50 65 years old
are starting to be more profound in the
younger
ages yes exactly and that's because
they're eating more fast foods they're
not putting wood ashes in their gardens
they're not raising gardens they're just
eating fast foods
and again i want to go back to the
filipinos versus the vietnamese
the um let's see here in addition to the
average lifespan
the vietnamese have 35 dead from the
pandemic
just 35 not 3 500 not 35 000 just 35
dead
they have 3030 infections
the filipinos they just a couple of days
ago crossed over a million they have 1
million 80
192 infections and they're the
um which i say
uh it's really scary they have
18 000 dead now as eighteen thousand
dead more than thirty five did
is one million eighty thousand more
infections than three thousand
okay it's all diet it's all
diet i actually had some um
pharmacists and technicians uh double
check me
and check out you know countries and
states of the same populations but
uh asian countries eating like asians
versus european countries
you know things like um some of my
favorites of course
uh are nigeria and brazil
both of them have about 208 million
people
and nigeria is 98 black
tribal africans
brazil is 47 percent white
uh immigrants from europe three four
hundred years ago
forty seven percent mulattos
biracial black and white and nine
percent black
okay now the nigerians at 98
black tribal people they have 2 000 dead
brazilians are the third leading number
of dead in the world
331 000 versus 2 000
and in nigeria they have 163 000
infections
versus brazil it has 13 million
infections same population
this is totally a different diet because
the nigerians they live on the west
coast of africa
they live on rice and sweet potatoes and
beans and squash and seaweed almost like
an asian
and the brazilians live like europeans
for the last 400 years they're eating
wheat bread around oats
and that's why there's this huge
dramatic difference in infection rate
and death rate in them i'll give you one
more here
and then i think it will you know be
right at the point where you need to
start
answering some questions and the next
one i want to talk about
let's do um you know a very famous state
for
we're talking about the sunshine state
um
let's do uh okay
let's do texas versus vietnam again
vietnam has 97 million people
texas has 29 million so texas about
one-third the size
of vietnam again vietnam has 35 dead
texas has 50 000 dead
texas has 2.9 million
infections and vietnam has 3030
infections so it's the difference well
again vietnam vietnam is 99.999
asian and they eat like asians and texas
depending on what county you're looking
at
there are 40 50 60 percent latinos
blacks
and indigenous peoples indian tribes who
live on nothing but wheat bran oats
and so their intestines are dead these
peoples are not
into supplementing okay it's not part of
their
um culture whereas the vietnamese
they're eating seaweed and kelp and
stuff which has all these weird trace
minerals
which your bone marrow loves okay to
make white blood cells and antibodies to
defend you
and so when you when you start making
these comparisons and you dig deeper why
is it that this country has or this
state
has so many deads and infections when
this there's another one down the line
with the same numbers
um it's totally different what it's diet
it's not race
and of course everybody wants to tell me
well it's a racial thing
no it's a dietary thing i can take say a
thousand
asians and feed them um a diet from the
inner city
right a black diet from the inner city
of new york or pennsylvania or something
like that
and they'll have a high rate of
infection in deaths
i can take um
black people say take a thousand of them
and feed them like asians and give them
the virus and they won't have any deaths
or infections
because it's a dietary thing it is not a
racial thing
so with that uh everybody needs to get
the red warning light cd
uh get a hold you know we have um 15
books
we've got a couple of new books coming
out here pretty quick i'm excited about
that
and um uh we have
over 100 cds we have over 50 dvds
lots of stuff for education they all
represent
lectures and research and so forth and
if people pay attention to that
and you know um if they're playing
tennis three days a week cut it down to
two days a week and spend
that one day you know give up that one
third day of tennis and spend time
reading and listening and
and learning how to add 25 to 50 health
for years to
live for your friends and families
so dr wallach i know that um
many of those books are also available
as
a kindle edition so for those who want
to get it on their electronic device
that is available
um and you can find dr wallach's most
popular books
at askdoclive.com so we do have a store
there that carries his books and i'm
very proud to be able to announce and
make it easy for you to find there
um but we also have a store there
that carries all of the products that dr
wallick is going to be mentioning
in today's program so again if somebody
share this program with you please get
back with them don't call
somebody else that you don't know get
back with the person you know because
they care about
you and they have an interest in making
sure that you get information
that is going to be beneficial to you so
we have some amazing certified health
coach pro um
health coaches um within our
organization
and many of them are here on with us
today which i think is absolutely
fantastic
dr wallach you're creating quite an army
quite an army well that was the whole
purpose of this
that's the whole purpose of this because
you know when you looked
um even moses had apostles that followed
him and angels that followed him and
carried on his works
even jesus had apostles and angels that
carried on his words
so if these wonderful sons and and
daughters of god
needed some help i needed help too
so that's why we decided to create an
army and follow their examples
and of course now we do have an army and
of course that's going to be the basis
of these books coming out oh
my gosh is really really crazy
um when you see what's going on here
because there has not been any new
edition of the bible in 2000 years
you think about it you're continuing on
the history
yes sir it's right we're going to
continue on the history okay
it was start that was started in the
bible you know
we're talking about um
miracles they're miracles all through
the old testament there's miracles for
all the
new new testament well we have
let's see here we documented um 83
miracles in the old testament
there's 80 miracles in the new testament
and right now we have
millions of miracles in over 50
countries
over the past of 73 years
okay and these are all all wonderful
tools that the good lord built we'll
give the good lord all the credit here
we we have just figured out a way to
expand his efforts and get all his
material out there
and we will give him all the credit
absolutely
absolutely and you know taking his
creation and putting them into formulas
that synergistically work together dr
wallach is what you've done
you've taken your research you've found
out what the body is supposed
to have what was missing when specific
diseases were current and it all came to
over
600 different diseases
are directly related to nutrient
deficiencies
that's correct it's scary when you think
about it if you think about again
in the old testament where did people
live the longest where were they the
healthiest well the land flowing with
milk and honey it wasn't all over the
world was just one place where people
lived the longest and
okay because they had more stuff there
okay
and they didn't know why but they just
knew that that was a place where
everybody did well
and then um when people were really good
and they helped a lot of people they
were known as the salt of the earth
did god say that salt was bad no salt is
good
only doctors say that salt is bad oh you
have edema you can't have salt
well why don't you get rid of the cause
of the edema you do you need salt
okay yeah so
so let's talk about dr wellick as we
exercise because i know
weather is starting to get um nicer
and more welcoming that sun is calling
us
out um getting more active
now when we're more active of course
we're gonna start
perspiring glistening sweating whatever
you want to
call it um but that's not just
water coming out of our bodies is it
well
has anybody ever licked their arm when
they had sweat in the back of their hand
does it taste wet when it's dripping
it's a little salty
yeah because your sweat contains
everything that's floating around in
your blood
okay and so when you look at people who
do
exercise they get paid for it you know
let's look at professional athletes
who get paid a lot of money uh for it um
the average lifespan of professional
athletes in some cases get paid millions
of dollars a game
okay we're talking about really high-end
people and so they're doing everything
right that they know
and um when you take all sports combined
their average lifespan is 62.
the average lifespan of somebody who's
lazy does nothing
eats everything bad is 75 united states
especially if they don't exercise
they'll live to be 75 if they exercise
62 except for basketball players is 51.
okay well that's why we came up with a
rebound our sports drink with
100 nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
vitamins and amino acids in it
okay all the other sports drinks are
really energy drinks you know like red
bull and gatorade and stuff like that
they have two or three nutrients in
there
a lot of caffeine and sugar and they
just came out a week or so ago
with another big study on soft drinks
and carbonated drinks they said oh
the people who drink even diet colas and
stuff like that
um they die uh 10 to 15 years before
people who don't drink those kind of
drinks
okay so if you want to start your life
by 10 to 15 years drink more
diet colas this is a university research
okay i'm just reporting what data is and
it's not me
picking on somebody i'm just reporting
this research that came out
and so you really really really really
have to pay attention
to what you're eating what you're
drinking what you're not eating what
you're not
drinking okay um because we do require
stuff
and of course we're getting some of it
here and there based on where people
lived
again because nutritional minerals don't
occur in a uniform plant around the
coast of the earth they occur in veins
like gold and silver
and there's places on earth where people
live a long time okay the people who
live the longest are up in the hunza
valley
by the guiltar glacier between pakistan
and china their average lifespan is
about 165
the oldest documented one was 265.
okay um dr lee chen young
and there was a book written about him
called lost horizon by james hilton they
made them in 1933 they made a movie out
of it 1937
same movie lost horizon and he was
james hilton was a very very vicious um
reporter an investigative reporter for
the new york times the london times
and they sent him to china to check out
this dr lee
and chun because he's selling herbs and
everything and telling people he's
uh 265 years old and so forth and so
these and he followed him for a year and
he said no this guy's real
okay and that's when he came up with the
book
and the movie and so everybody needs to
watch those things and read the book and
watch the movie
and of course these new books will just
blow your mind
uh when they come out here in a few
weeks
well i'm i'm excited to be able to read
them i love
all of the books i've got a few of yours
right there
and i have a few overs here and
i love to be able to have them as
resources doctor while i can mm-hmm
well that's what they're there for you
look things up and of course
it's not just it's not a book that you
just read through once and then put it
away on the shelf
it's something that you can refer back
to time and time
again okay and there's lots of
references in each one of them
absolutely absolutely lots of references
yeah so people don't have to take my
word for it okay because we reference
everything so then go back to the
original research
and of course one of my favorite studies
was done by johns hopkins they came they
looked at the
eight um most common causes of death in
american hospitals this came out about a
year ago
okay it'll be two years in august is
coming august
and they came out and said um there's
eight major causes of death in american
hospitals number one is heart disease
what was it the heart attack that killed
the people going in there or was it the
treatment for the heart attack or was it
50 50
treatment and the heart attack number
two is cancer
again was it the cancer that killed him
in the hospital or was it the treatment
chemotherapy and radiation all that kind
of stuff right
but the one that really got me really
brought tear to my eye
was number three the number three cause
of death in american hospital now this
is johns hopkins very famous medical
school
baltimore maryland very famous um
university baltimore maryland johns
hopkins
not me i'm just reporting what they said
he said the number three cause of death
in american hospitals each year not
households in the world but just
american hospitals
is medical errors
your doctor makes a mistake in dosage he
gives the wrong medicine
he gives the medicine from one patient
to a different patient you know pick the
wrong patient or something
medical errors is the third leading
cause of death in american hospitals
and so if they prevent doctors from
going into hospitals and treating people
more people will survive it's crazy
over to you rebecca yeah so those
medical errors don't always end in death
dr wallach and people just have to
suffer with the results of them and that
that's what kills me i see people every
day i have people in my family that have
been
through that and you know
once once the damage is done even
supplementation
in some cases is not helpful that's
correct that's not helpful
so all right well dr wallach
let's go ahead and move on let's go to
some happier subjects and start helping
some people that are here
in the line with us so again everybody
you this program is sponsored by
askdoclive.com
we do have a website there and on that
website we are going to have this
recording
of this program and all of our past
programs
since the day that we started are all
there so as you are going through and
asking
questions i know dr wallach speaks very
quickly
but you can go back to the recording
and read listen to it as many times as
you need to
to make sure that you get everything
that he has mentioned
so i want everybody to take advantage of
that and share those videos with people
so there are some descriptions there
that will help you be able to do a
search and find out what
conditions are mentioned on the program
and then you can share that specific
program
with somebody that you care about
let's go to the first hand of
dr wallach and that is barney
barney go ahead and unmute yourself i
see you have your camera on thank you so
much
you are on live with dr wallach
hey doc um hi i
um talked to you last year around
october
for some tinnitus and numbness in the
hands
but since then i
ended up with sepsis and that ate away
my heart valve and i had to have it
replaced
and so i've been taking um
warfarin and your tangy tangerine and
your d3 both have vitamin
k in them and do you know what do you
know what warfarin is
yeah it's a blood thinner no it's a rat
poison
it makes rats bleed to death warfarin is
a
rat killer okay now
how old are you and how much do you
weigh barney um
i'm 61 years old weigh 175 pounds
and six foot tall okay do you have any
other issues how about pressure diabetes
anything like that
no okay well just for our listeners when
you have tinnitus when you have ringing
in the ears
uh and your hands are tingling and numb
and so forth um that means you have
osteoporosis of the skull it's not an
age thing it's not an autoimmune thing
it's just osteoporosis
which includes the skull we have a book
out called it's all in your head 25
different diseases you get
from osteoporosis skull tinnitus is
ringing in the ears oftentimes you get
dizziness with it did you have any
dizziness or vertigo or anything like
that
um no occasionally when i stand up too
quick
and the answer and the answer is yes
because you have osteoporosis a skull
and then when you have numbness and
tingling in your hands your doctors
might say oh you have carpal tunnel
syndrome but really
is your skull squeezing the spinal cord
coming out of the back your skull
even doctors don't remember their
anatomy because
your spinal cord is formed in your brain
not in your neck and your back
your spinal cord is formed in the brain
comes out of the big hole in the back
your skull called foramen magnum which
is latin for big whole
and as that spinal cord gets squeezed
when you have osteoporosis skull
you start getting numbness and tingling
in your hands it's kind of like
peripheral neuropathies in your feet and
toes okay
um where you get low back stuff you get
um
sciatica um when you get numbness and
tingling in your toes it's not a
toes and an ankle problem it's your
lower back when you get numbness and
tingling in your hands it's not a hand
problem
it's a neck problem and a skull problem
okay
and then sepsis of course um is
kind of an infection in your body and
again um
i want to see people using our colloidal
silver
okay and two droppers full on your
tongue and
if you take ultimate daily classic
tablets ultimate daily classic tablets
take three of those your body weight
um 175 pounds once you take three of
those
twice a day um they will support and
promote
healthy blood pressure but they will
also support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries whether it's in your
eyes your brain
um your heart uh your kidneys and so
forth
legs wherever and um say ultra daily
classic tablets that's in addition to
the healthy abandoned heart pack
die 175 pounds like you need two health
advantage heart packs per month
hold those everything twice a day and
again i'm saying this for not only you
but for your listening audience here
um you need two bottles a month of our
msm so you can take three with each meal
they're gonna support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes your bone
itself
don't forget vitamin d3 take three of
those twice a day that's two bottles a
month
that'll help absorb minerals
particularly calcium and put it in your
bones and things like supposed to
and don't forget for the sepsis thing
you know if you're taking antibiotics i
would still take
two droppers full of our colloidal
silver under the tongue 30 minutes for
each meal
30 minutes before bedtime and i go
through about two of these bottles
per month been doing it for 25 years and
again i'm 82 years old and don't have
any of these problems
okay but i can tell do you have varicose
veins in your legs or spider veins your
feet or legs or anything like that no i
don't
you have some gray hair in your mustache
in your hair yes
okay well all those things are not
caused by aging
they're caused by nutritional
deficiencies and it's the same
nutritional deficiency that cause
problems in the valves in your heart
okay
and doctors want to blame it on a lot of
things but it's just nutritional
deficiencies
okay and so you got to get rid of the
bad stuff you cannot have one cheat day
a month
not one cheat meal a month uh you got to
be
free of all the bad stuff no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread right notice no sugar
and i get people who i mean we're
completely bald i mean you have quite a
bit of hair lift but i've got people who
are like a bowling ball
they've been completely bald for 40
years and just after three months
on our program okay getting all the bad
stuff to maximize absorption taking all
the good stuff
their hair grew back like it was when
they're 12 years old you know
the original color without any gray or
white hair and so it's an amazing
um talent if you will that your body has
to be able to rebuild itself and
maintain itself
but you have to avoid the bad stuff so
you can maximize efficiency of
absorption
and you have to consciously consciously
supplement with the 90 cents of
nutrients because you can't depend on
what may or may not be
in the food otherwise you're really in
trouble before you even start
okay so keep in touch call us every
couple of weeks don't wait two years
call us every couple of weeks and
whether anything's happening or not give
us a call and nothing's happening yet
okay we'll talk to you some more and so
on and see what's going on
um but anytime you go into the doctor's
office they do a blood test or they do
some kind of exam
call us let us know what the doctor said
what the blood test showed
because we have a lot of people who are
middle-aged like yourself who are 60
years old
61 years old okay whatever it is
and you want to be sure that they're
getting this information
because they want to they they're hoping
and praying you're going to do well
so they can do what you do so they can
all actually get the same benefit also
okay but what about the warfarin um
and okay so what you want to do
is if you're taking all the 90 essential
nutrients you're going to avoid blood
clots
which is the purpose of them giving you
rat poison that's why
warfarin kills rats because they bleed
to death they don't they don't have
any clotting in their blood and so i
wouldn't be real happy about my doctor
giving me rat poison
okay so what you want to do is i'd go to
a different cardiologist and say hey
is this warfarin dose correct or is
there another you know anti-clotting
pharmaceutical i should be taking i
really don't like the idea of taking rat
poison
you reduce this dose here and let
another doctor at the other end of town
who doesn't know the one who's given you
rat poison
you know reduce it yeah we can reduce it
ten percent okay
then you go back to you know to him
again a month later whenever he says
you know uh your blood clotting time is
really
uh too long here so we're going to
reduce it again it might take him three
months to slowly reduce and eliminate
that warframe
you don't do it cold turkey you do it by
the test okay
yeah okay keep in touch with us let us
know how it goes but i'd go to a
different doctor
and ask you know to test for your blood
clotting time say you know i really
don't like the idea of taking rat poison
so what can we do here to make sure i'm
not going to get blood clots i am taking
supplements
and if that doctor says oh you shouldn't
be taking supplements and leave that
doctor find a different doctor
okay but the vitamin k does interfere
with the warfarin and well that's a good
thing otherwise you'll bleed to death
yeah okay
remember warfarin causes rats to die
because they bleed to death because it
prevents blood clotting
i get it so dr wallace there's
there's natural things that we can do to
thin the blood clean the blood
well yeah that's that's what the 90
essential nutrients are for
you stay away from the bad stuff no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens and wheat bread around oats
and then um there's several of these
nutrients
in the 90th cents nutrients that prevent
abnormal blood clotting people say which
one is it which one is it and i used to
tell them what it was
and then they would go to you know like
walgreens and buy that one nutrient and
three months later they died i said what
happened to your husband i haven't heard
well he died three months after you told
him what to do what
did he take all 90 essential nutrients
no he just took that one
well that's why he died he died from the
stupid gene
so everything works synergistically
together within the body
our doesn't need just one specific
nutrient any doctor who just gives you
warfarin
and you have all these issues somebody
needs to go to jail here
yeah um yeah so um dr wallach
we've got a question in the chat here
that says what can a person
using blood thinners take in place of
efas
there is no such thing to replace efas
it's kind of like saying
what can i take to replace oxygen what
can i replace take to replace water
okay you can't do it okay the essential
nutrients are essential nutrients
okay it's not the essential nutrients
fault if you have a problem
is it because you're not absorbing it
because you're taking a pharmaceutical
that mask it so it can't do its job
okay um you know just like these
professional athletes to diet 62 or 51.
they're these people are eating well i
mean some of their meals cost them a
couple hundred bucks a meal
i mean they are eating the best foods
and and taking the best pharmaceuticals
and all that kind of stuff
and they die early
30 years early okay or 50 years early
you know 51 athletes should be super
centenarians every professional athlete
in the university athlete
every athlete who's in the olympics
should live to be 110 or more
but they eat improperly they don't
supplement properly and so the exercise
becomes a negative
it's like you know you drive your car 30
miles an hour you got oil in there
and you got lubricants and all this kind
of stuff and coolant
but if you don't have any of those
things in there driving 30 miles an hour
your car will still burn up and die
just like our bodies well that's exactly
right
yeah and with efas essential fatty acids
they're essential because the body can't
make them
we have to take them in right and so not
only yeah
not only do they reduce the risk of
blood clots but they're also required
for the for the biochemical
structure and function of the cell walls
of every cell in your body your brain
your eyes your heart your lungs your
thyroid gland
your liver your kidneys your muscles
your bones your cartilage
blood vessels every tissue cell in the
body
requires efas for the membranes and
every cell to function properly
yeah it's amazing what just you know
adding the 90 essential nutrients
people don't believe that it's going to
help but it
it's so simple so simple
yeah try going without oxygen for a
couple hours
no thanks
[Laughter]
like living love living
so director well again has a testimonial
um she says that i've taken the
youngevity products for years and have
finally gotten serious about getting off
the bad stuff
gluten etc and i have lost 15
pounds wow so that's awesome janna
congratulations on that
and next let's go to a question that has
been submitted um
there we go so
i have a client who is 46 years old
she is gluten free and eats healthy
she's fine
i know five foot seven 126
pounds um she thinks that she
is in perimenopause with spotty periods
some are missed some are very heavy and
she has mental fog
she is looking for the best female
hormonal product
that she can use to help her as she is
on a budget okay
well in addition to getting rid of all
the bad foods which she says she's doing
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens and wheat brought around
so sugar
she also needs to eat three eggs twice a
day with soft yolks hard-boiled eggs
won't count fridays cause cancer
soft boiled eggs with soft yolks soft
poached eggs with soft yolks soft soft
soft soft runny scrambled eggs and
butter
because 95 percent of the weight of
estrogen is cholesterol she cannot be
taking statin drugs
she cannot be avoiding eggs right and
she's foggy
75 of the brain weight is cholesterol
duh
okay so um
then she should also be taking in
addition to her 90 essential nutrients
she might have some osteoporosis in the
skull
so she needs to take the msm take three
of those twice a day to support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the rubber bay bone makes bone
itself
artery walls vein walls i also want her
to take vitamin d three three of those
twice a day
okay that's two bowels a mouth so i can
absorb minerals particularly calcium and
put them in all the right places
and then uh to answer a very specific
question she had we have what we call
zero femme
okay is the raw materials for ovaries to
make estrogen and progesterone so i
wanted to get two bottles of that a
month so she could take three of those
twice a day or two three times a day for
a total of six a day of the zero fm
um and i also want her to take the
woman's fx you could take three of those
twice a day
the woman's fx okay and that's gonna
give her
things that are going to support all the
stuff
that she's trying to do here with her
cycles and this and the other
now 46 years of age is a little bit
early to be going through menopause
most women who are healthy and doing
everything correctly they will still
have regular cycles and healthy cycles
proper levels of of
their their cycle and so forth
um at age in their 50s and early 60s
okay and so when they're having problems
at age 46 this means
she has an absorption problem she has a
deficiency problem or both
and all this kind of stuff and so um
we have these programs we've been doing
for over 50 years and so we help a lot
of women going through what she's going
through
doctors will give you a lot of bad
advice
well and so it kills me dr wallach
you know we think that pain is all part
of getting old
we think that cramps are part of the
men's
menstrual cycle no and
it's so untrue it's so untrue
that's correct i know for myself
i mean i don't even get moodiness just
ask me but
um but i love
not having what so many people are
complaining about
with with the cramping and with the mood
swings and
just aching all over
well do do many of these do many of
these people ever ask you rebecca what
are you doing you're always so happy and
so for what are you doing different what
do i need to do here
i do have people that ask they said oh i
take supplements
i take cup of centrum every single day
yeah 27 nutrients
yeah not even a third and then they're
from rock dr wallach
so you shared with us last week the
difference between
minerals from rock and minerals that
have been processed through a plant
that is correct one is almost 100
absorbable and the other one is only a
couple percent absorbable
yeah so oh goodness
so we are coming to the top of the hour
but let's see if we can fit
one more question in dr wallach okay
let's go to john john go ahead and
unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
yes sir how can we help you um
i guess i'm reporting after a couple of
weeks
uh really not feeling much change yet
but i
okay well stop stop stop you got to
remind me how old you are
yeah um i'm 63
how much you a five five foot five two
two
sixteen okay and what were your
complaints a couple weeks ago
well i have the afib
cardio cardiomyopathy
ed okay i i remember you now
okay now you have to appreciate you have
osteoporosis of the skull
yeah okay and so that's not going to
um which i say heal itself completely
in two weeks okay
and so you really need to crank down get
rid of all the bad stuff you need to
really crank down take everything we
talked about
okay um two healthy brain heart packs
msm
vitamin d3 ultimate daily classic
um you need to be taking the glucogel
and the fucoid z
all that kind of stuff okay okay
glucogel absolutely
before yep all that stuff and again this
is for our listeners so that they're all
getting
the same information and uh i i take
people who
i had a big um wager with the eye doctor
eye surgeon
and i said i could reverse macular
degeneration blindness and he gave me 27
of his patients that he had diagnosed he
couldn't argue with the diagnosis
they were legally blind 6 8 10 12 years
and to make a long story short
put him on the same program and put you
on and in 90 days
in 90 days remember they're legally
blind six eight ten twelve years and
he's an eye doctor so he's the one that
made the diagnosis not me couldn't argue
with the diagnosis because it was his
diagnosis
in 90 days all of them could read 20 20
without glasses okay because i was able
to rebuild the skull take the pressure
off the optic nerve
and the optic artery and the optic vein
okay which really messes around with the
with the eyes so you get what's what's
called ona
optic nerve atrophy and of course
doctors don't know about this and so
they say well you have max regeneration
but then um they say no
you don't have cataracts because i can
see a cataract but even without a
you know without an ophthalmoscope you
know i could just look at your eye with
a naked eye and see the cataract if you
got one
uh same way with um blood pressure and
pressure in the eye okay glaucoma that's
all caused by ost
you have that too yes osteoporosis of
the skull squeezing that
optic nerve but also squeezing the
artery going into the eye and squeezing
the vein coming back out of the eye
so all these things going on are all
secondary to osteoporosis of the skull
of course you have other things going on
all over the place
cardiomyopathy heart disease is a
specific nutrient deficiency
afib is not a heart issue afib
can be squeezing of the first four
thoracic spinal nerves okay kind of like
a peripheral neuropathy
that can be caused by um osteoporosis of
the skull
squeezing the tenth cranial nerve the
vagus nerve do you ever get hiccups
no okay good you ever have dry
unproductive cough like copd
not not really much maybe a the odd time
but
okay every once in a while okay yeah
yeah okay yeah
so these are all caused by osteoporosis
call so keep calling
call us every couple of weeks okay and
pay attention to details
okay call us every couple of weeks it's
toll free so it's not gonna run up your
phone bill
and just you know give us give us a kind
of live talk like we're doing now
um every couple of weeks and there's
gonna come a point when oh my gosh
this point is getting better that
point's getting better but it might take
four five
six weeks okay depending on the severity
yeah yeah okay
uh the i i the main reason for my call
today was
uh it was about my sister she got a call
yesterday that she's got cancer
so okay we'll tell you what this is
going to be a little lengthy here so
let's take our break here and um okay
and rebecca will make sure that you're
on whether you're going to hang on or
you're going to go away and come back
in five minutes or whatever let us take
our break here
and then that way we can don't have to
hurry through your sister's diagnosis
okay okay you want me to uh
you talked you talked a little bit back
up john we'll get you
you want me to send the text of the
information a bit
um you directly you can also call back
on you and you can just go over it
okay i'll put my hand back up thank you
yeah
so thank you everybody go ahead and
get up stretch run to the little
kids room whatever you need to do
we are going to take about a five minute
break and we will be right back with
more of
askdoclive.com a reminder we do have the
recordings of our program
we have a store with all of the products
that are mentioned today inclu and dr
wallick's books
they can all be found at askdoclive.com
now again if somebody referred you to
this program
you don't want to use the store that's
there you want to get back with them
because they have their
own store or their own source of
getting the products and you want to
make sure that you are supporting the
person that
share this information with you so we
will be right back
don't go away
all right welcome back everybody as dr
wallach is coming back on
with us i just want to again thank you
for joining us with the askdoc
live program again this program is
brought to you as a community service
and resource
there are so many things out there that
we can do
on our own as we are empowered
individuals
and the things that we are sharing here
today are
nutritional approaches to being able to
obtain and
maintain better health
there are so many things that we have
grown accustomed to
just accepting that it's part of getting
old and i'm here to say
that old age does not have to hurt we do
not have to have disease
um it's those things are
all preventable and in many cases they
can even be reversed
so i am honored and privileged
to be able to bring to you dr
wallach dr wallach if you could go ahead
and unmute yourself
um let's go ahead and continue on with
the program
can you hear me now we can hear you now
fabulously thank you so much
so before we get back to john dr wallach
nassema had a couple questions last week
that we didn't
have a chance to get to we ran out of
time
okay so nasima if you could go ahead
and unmute yourself and ask dr wallick
the questions that you have
hello nasima i know she's
here
oh maybe she's not back from break yet
but um
so let's i'm back
i'm here i'm here i talked to wallach
thank you for watching
you got a huge echo i can't understand
you so you got to do something i don't
know what it is but you got a huge echo
oh
um
see my i think it's just the the your
the room you're in i don't think there's
a technical issue
oh okay then maybe i'll ask the question
not at the time
try opening your doors in a sema because
that'll let
if you have glass doors behind you open
those
is that better
say again is that better
a little bit you have to speak slowly
okay
okay so doctor the first client's
question that i have she's a 12 year old
girl was born with freedor
willie synderome which is
um
i'm not exactly sure what that is but
she can't stop
eating she also has
pulmonary hypertension now look on the
internet what trader willie cinderell
means
in the meantime she also has pulmonary
hypertension
scoliosis and core pulmonary
okay how much does she weigh how much
does she weigh
um she weighs 60 kilograms
so 130 pounds and she also has
type 2 diabetes and she was diagnosed
with the scoliosis at
age 3. okay all right well she's got an
absorption problem none of these are
genetic none of them are autoimmune
they're all just simple nutritional
deficiency diseases
and so i don't know if she's fed a
formula if she's fed wombat milk or
she's breastfed or
we don't know any of that but she she
has to get rid of all the gluten out of
her life everybody in that family
grandma
mom dad brother and sister renters
school mates dog cat bird fish everybody
including her has got to be drop dead
gluten free
and then at 130 pounds i wanted her to
have one healthy brain heart pat per
month
she needs to get another bottle of water
selenium so you can take three twice a
day or two with each meal
okay for a total of six a day of the our
selenium
not from walgreens our selenium then
she's also going to need
our msm get one bottle a month for the
msm so you can take six of those a day
two of each meal or three twice a day
whichever is easier for her
then because she has this uh hubble
pressure stuff
she needs the ultimate daily classic
tablet she needs three of those
twice a day there's two bottles a month
support healthy blood pressure
and healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries and she has type 2 diabetes
she needs two bottles a month of the
sweetie so you can take three of those
twice a day or two
three times a day for a total of six a
day and she cannot cold turkey off if
she's on medication she can't pull
turkey off the medication but
as her blood sugar drops she can slowly
reduce medication
okay so i think that covers all of her
issues
and um i think we've covered all her
issues and so you know
thank you doc and i looked up on the
internet brady
raider really said yeah it says it's a
genetic disorder
caused by a loss of function of specific
genes on chromosome 15.
have you ever heard of the science of
crapola
crapola okay yeah all of these things
are caused by nutritional deficiencies
of gluten
okay and she may have a
issue with one chromosome but that's not
causing all these things
okay these are all caused by nutritional
deficiencies
and that's the difference between
genetics
and epigenetics give her all the
nutrients maximize
absorption and most of this if not all
of it will go away within weeks or
months
thank you doc the second client's
question
you know is there such a thing as
hypertension
only in the head because this girl
20 year old her doctor is saying to go
to the eye doctor if the pressure builds
up behind the optic
nerve okay well what would cause that
pressure to go up
behind the optic nerve osteoporosis of
the skull how old is this person
20 year old but i don't have the weight
or anything
yeah okay and so yeah it could be
glaucoma
um you see when you have osteoporosis
you'd be born with it the mother is not
getting right nutrition can't give all
the nutrients to the embryo so the
baby's born with osteoporosis skull
it's not an aging thing okay it's
nutritional deficiencies
and um the optic nerve comes out of the
brain through the skull
to the back of the eye but also the
artery that feeds the eye goes
from the brain along with that optic
nerve into the back of the eye
and the vein bringing the fluid back
from the eye you can't just keep pumping
stuff into the eye
you gotta you know and so the the vein
coming back from the eye back into the
skull
goes along with that optic artery so as
the optic nerve is being squeezed so is
the optic or the optic vein being
squeezed
causes all these problems okay and so
um this will be one where there's magic
we need to know you know how much he
weighs
and what other things are going on um
because usually when you have that kind
of stuff going on they have ringing in
the ears they have skin pumps they have
eggs you know they've got
ibs cerebral bowel syndrome they've had
appendicitis and all this kind of stuff
um which tells you there's more going on
than just
in her eye thank you doctor
okay you you are a super angel thank you
so much
thank you thank you nasima
all right dr welling let's go ahead and
go back to
john and let's get uh
his sister for his sister
okay john how old is your sister how
much does she weigh and what other
issues does she have
okay so uh she's been okay so she's uh
she's gonna be 70 in november
so i guess if you want to count her nine
months she's no just just keep going i
got other people
okay so she wait i don't have her weight
but i would uh i would
say it's probably around 170 i think
she's about
five two five three
okay any any other issues besides she's
been having
um she's been having asthma lung issues
for a number of years
she had a scan a year ago didn't show
anything but then she had a scan this
year
and they say she has small cell
lung cancer that has spread to her liver
two lesions on her lungs and one on her
liver
it is a very aggressive cancer at stage
four the next
spot it will seek out to spread is brain
and bone
i have a ct scan okay that's that's
enough
i get it okay okay so um
when you're in stage four cancer this is
really a very very life-threatening
thing and you know we can't make any
guarantees here
but some people say you know the doctors
say well she's got maybe
stage four she might have a couple of
months to live well we take people like
that
including coretta scott king okay the
wife of
dr martin luther king she
had stage four cancer and they only gave
her a couple of months to live and she
lived four more years after we began
to give her a program so you can
actually maximize
life and increase the quality of life
even though you're stage four cancer if
you do these things
she needs to do the same as you get rid
of all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth notice no sugar
no carbonated drinks at 170 pounds i
wanted to have two of the healthy brain
and heart pasture month to full dose
everything twice a day
i wanted her to take the msm i wanted to
get two bottles of those so she could
take three with each meal
and support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between a
vertebrae bone makes your bone cell
and i also want her to have vitamin d3
three of those
with each meal that's a nine a day
that's three bottles amounts to the
vitamin d tree to absorb minerals and
put them in the right places
and to support our immune system i want
her to have the fucoid
z capsules i wanted to take three with
each meal that'll be nine a day that's
three bottles a month
it's all these weird trace minerals from
the algae and seaweed from the oceans
and the bone marrow loves it and the
bone marrow is going to help support her
immune system
and also send out the white blood cells
and antibodies to help attack
the cancer cells but i do want to hear
from you every couple of weeks
about yourself i want to hear every
couple of weeks about your sister
anytime she goes in for a cat scan or
ultrasound or
blood test and all kind of stuff same
way with you so we keep up with what's
going on
and we can tweak things and make things
better um
and so i do expect to hear from you both
for yourself and your sister
okay you bet she's okay start chemo next
week
okay well yeah we've told you what to do
i will
i will pass on the news and i thank you
very much for your time okay
okay god bless okay rebecca what's going
on
all right thank you john dr wallach
let's go to the next hand that
is up um uchi go ahead and unmute
yourself
you are online with dr wallach
okay hi uchi
hi dr orleans okay i have
probably okay okay wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute where are you from
originally
i'm from nigeria okay okay go ahead
okay i have a several questions that my
friends
asked so i said okay i will ask there in
the program
i joined a program that from the
uk for women they were talking about hot
flash
and so many people said that they even
some of the doctors
said that a hot flash causes a dementia
and some women is it true and if it's
true what are the
supplements that will stop the hot flash
okay okay stop you're saying that some
of these women are complaining about
dementia and the doctors are blaming
that on the hot flashes
yeah okay all right
we have to appreciate that 75 percent of
the brain weight is cholesterol
you cannot be on statin drugs lower
cholesterol okay
must get rid of all the bad foods that
cause inflammation no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat by rhinos no sugar
and then um is she your size or smaller
it's smaller smaller okay how much you
weigh
it's about between 50 and
60. age 50 to cch
of age and then the weight is about 56
to
60 kg okay 60 kg so maybe 140 150 pounds
okay
all right okay so we want her to get rid
of all the bad stuff
and then we want her to take um two of
the healthy brain and heart patch per
month full dose everything twice a day
two healthy brain heart packs
a month i want her to get the msm two
bottles of that a month so i can take
three with each meal that's gonna
support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes your bone
itself
i want her also to eat three eggs twice
a day with soft yolks
hard-boiled eggs won't count fried eggs
cause cancer
soft yolks a poached soft yolk soft
boiled
soft soft soft soft yolks scrambled in
butter
okay three twice a day she can have
three three times a day if she wants but
no less than three twice a day
because 75 of the brain weight is
cholesterol then i also want her to have
de-stress capsules she needs to take
three of those twice it has two bottles
a month
i also want her to have our woman's fx
take three of those twice a day that's
two dollars a month
and then one of our secret sauces for
this is
the um xerifem
x-e-r-a-f-e-m okay xerifem
is the raw materials for the ovaries to
make more estrogen
okay so i want her to have three of
those twice a day
and you got to watch it she can't just
take the zero femme she needs the eggs
and she needs to get rid of the bad food
she needs to take all these other
supplements we just talked about
because if he just takes it to their fm
she's not going to get maximum benefit
okay and so you got to watch that you
got to be careful
that she knows she's got to do the whole
program if she wants to get maximum
benefit
okay yeah okay so actually what uh
what they say the doctor said that she
has to increase her estrogen
well that's what we're doing she's
getting the eggs okay 95 percent of the
weight of estrogen is cholesterol
then she's getting the supplement a xero
femme
she's getting women's effects and she's
getting all the 90 cents of nutrients
and this will help her make more
estrogen
don't let her have the doctor give her
prescription pharmaceutical estrogen
okay she can make her own okay then
another question
is that the person when she goes to
another person when she wants to go and
eat herself before she runs to the
toilet
then the way we had already dropped as
the urine has already dropped
now what is the cost that is
okay i'm not getting a whole lot here
because you got a big echo but i heard
something happens with her urine when
she wants to go to the bathroom
yeah it drops so it sounds like she's
starting to urinate dr wallach before
she gets to the bathroom
oh okay so she okay so she okay so she's
got some
um she can't she incontinent she can't
control it
okay yeah yeah and this can be a back
problem okay that's why i wanted to have
the msm
and the vitamin d3 because back problems
squeeze the nerves to control the
bladder
doctors either forget that are there
kids in college
and they want to treat her so that they
can pay the tuition
so this is the this is the second person
so yes nutrients with the brain and
heart pack
the msm gluco
correct dr wallach that's correct and of
course
um the the glucogel and and don't forget
the fucoid z
we want to get the bones and all the
nerves and everything good shape because
99 of the time in these cases it's the
nerves controlling the bladder that are
being squeezed
by her back because she's got
osteoporosis degenerative disc disease
and all that kind of stuff going on in
her back
okay then the final question is
most of them my the
my church members we had this problem in
the church recently
that um some people will go to bed they
are active
like today then they will go to bed then
they will not wake up from sleep so what
is
then some people like okay somebody okay
stop somebody has to tell me what she
just said because all i get is echo
okay what i said is that no no i
have i cannot understand you rebecca you
have to tell me what she said
unfortunately i didn't catch up for any
everything
um okay i'm sorry i think what she's
saying
if i may rebecca is some people in her
church
are having issues where when they go to
sleep at bed
that time they just don't wake up
and yes
okay well um this is not uncommon and we
advise
we advise that we should start taking
and taking a spring maybe because
it's a rupture of the brain
that causes a bleeding in the brain
okay there's a hundred different things
there's a hundred different things okay
and so she these people somebody needs
to do an autopsy and some of these
people that go go
to sleep and don't wake up dead okay and
so somebody needs to do an autopsy on
them and find out what killed them
oh because you're going to guess here
there's a hundred different things
okay that can cause the problem okay so
it's a spring
this has been good for me and every
other person of
50 to 60 years to take to start taking
as a precaution
okay um i'm going to leave now because i
can't understand what she's saying
yeah she said is it is it a good idea to
take
aspirin or should she stop no aspirin
no aspirin of course
uh can reduce the risk of blood clots
but it also can cause bleeding
okay and so it's one of those things
where you don't know what you're dealing
with
are they bleeding to death in the brain
do you want to keep taking aspirin bleed
to death in the brain
okay we don't know and so
rather than just guessing needs get rid
of all the bad foods take the 90
essential nutrients
and somebody needs to find out what
these people are dying from i remember
talking about one a year we're talking
about 10 a month i mean
you know we need more information here
to find out if this is just a random
thing
or if it's some big thing going on
because they have lead in the water at
the church i mean who knows i mean
you know we need to find out and just
guessing
won't help anybody okay
all right thank you jay thank you
you're welcome so dr wallick the next
question
is um beatrice has a lady that she
is working with she's 77 years old
5 foot 7 125 pounds
she woke up one morning and could not
breathe properly
she went to the doctor and she was told
she is highly anemic
she's still having breathing problems
she can only walk a few steps
and then she has to stop and
well you went away i don't hear anything
yeah um
rebecca your screen is frozen so
in the meantime while rebecca fixes her
technical issue there we see a hand
raised
by elaine elaine i'd i'd like to ask you
to unmute yourself
and be aware of my video yes thank you
go ahead all right um
i have a question um i recently went to
the doctor and i was
um diagnosed with hypercalcemia
and i've had i am taking uh tangy
tangerine
and done very well to help me with my
asthma
um i'm wondering
my question is i had a thyroid strand
elaine elaine just one moment please are
you available by
video as well and doctor would like to
address your question
um i'm not at video at the moment okay
okay i know he wants my weight age want
me to start there doc
yeah okay uh 150
5 6 60 years old and so basically my
question is on my thyroid issue
okay um thyroid parathyroid
when you have elevated blood calcium
it's almost always a parathyroid problem
that means you're not absorbing calcium
you're not getting enough calcium for
one reason or another and your
parathyroid glands are over
reacting they're pulling calcium out of
your bones
and people say well how can i be getting
too much calcium i don't even supplement
with calcium well that's because your
parathyroids are pulling calcium out of
your bones
and elaine you're a perfect candidate to
get a hair analysis get the book
and the cd called rare earthworm cures
chapter nine it'll tell you how to
collect the hair how to package it where
to ship it don't forget to put the check
in they won't run the test without the
check
and we want to find out um what's going
on
with the minerals in your body there's
two charts so one that goes into the
essential
minerals okay and the other one goes
into toxic minerals like lead and
and um mercury and that kind of stuff
okay
and so we need a hair analysis to find
out to answer the question
but the odds are that it's the
um uh it has to do
with the parathyroid gland
pulling calcium out of your bones
okay and they say that the parathyroid
has shrunk and that it's not working
effectively obviously um is that
something that can be restored
of course but you can't be able to
absorb it so she's got to give her all
the bad stuff then she's got to take all
the good stuff then we have to find out
what's going on here in detail
okay when you start having argon and
gland shutdowns you have some serious
problems here
and so it's definitely worth it to get
that hair analysis done
so we can find out exactly what's
happening and doctors say oh your
parathyroids aren't working well how do
they know
okay um i didn't hear any tests that
they did for the parathyroid glands
they're just guessing
okay so we need to find out we did one i
did one scan but you know what i'm gonna
do the hair analysis and then call you
back yeah
okay good thank you so much thank you
okay let's keep going here i'm getting
calls stacking up
okay uh doc i have the information
that rebecca started asking about from
beatrice oliver
um she is 77 years old
5 feet 7 inches tall 125
pounds she woke one morning and could
not breathe properly
went to the doctor and was told she has
high
highly anemia she is having breathing
problems
she can only walk a few steps
and she has to stop and rest up
what can she take to get her strength
back
okay well first of all the odds are she
has osteoporosis of the skull she has
maybe asthma and anemia okay
she may have a squeezing uh i don't know
if she's got anything going on with her
heart
okay regular heartbeat afib fast heart
rate slow heart rate
um so at 125 pounds i wanted to get rid
of all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oil
somebody's stirring coffee or something
oh sorry doc it was me not
okay so you gotta get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meat
no oils no gluten so we brought it right
on oats no sugar
and then at 125 pounds i wanted to get
one healthy brain and heart fat per
month
another bottle of water slim so you
should take three of those twice a day
okay and a half of those everything else
twice a day i want her to get one bottle
of the msm so you can take three twice a
day that'll support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone rich
bone itself and being anemic
she can be not absorbing stuff because
her intestines are dead because she's
eating gluten
okay in her bone marrow can be dead
because she couldn't absorb nutrition to
maintain her bone marrow to make red
blood cells
okay and she could be not absorbing
omega-3 essential fatty acids which
result in
a breathing issue but if you're severely
anemic you can also have a breathing
issue because you can't carry enough
oxygen if you don't have enough red
blood cells
so all those kind of things are going on
there
and so um and see here i'd also have her
take a few quiet z
she can take three of those twice as two
bottles a month
and let's see here
i also want her to take
the or she needs eggs she needs three
eggs twice a day with soft yolks
that's going to help her maintain her
brain
and also what's going on in her bone
marrow
excuse me and let's start there that's a
lot
but she's got some problems which can be
life-threatening here
all right thank you so much dr wallach i
just love technology
so fabulous when it works
okay what's next
okay perhaps there's still some issues
going on
so doc kathy jacobs has um
a question here she says i took your
advice about a year ago and got off
all the bad foods especially sugar
i recently ordered tangy tangerine
which has tapioca meldextrin
osteo effects and herbal rainforest
both contain fructose i'm concerned
about this much
sweetener what are your thoughts
okay well when you have 210 nutrients in
a product
it can either be bitter or acidic or
this any other so there has to be a
little bit of sweetener in there
we're not talking about tablespoons of
sugar here we're talking about a few
drops
in the capsules and so that's not going
to
cause any problems but it's good she's
reading labels
thank you doc so we will go to the next
person who has their hands
up and that is yunette net i'm gonna ask
you to unmute yourself
and be available by video
hello united okay
i guess i don't i don't um
see her being on hello
oh there you are okay go ahead you net
with your question please
hi good afternoon dr um walek
hello can you i'm getting a little bit
of an echo here so you're going to have
to speak clearly
hello okay okay that's better
okay i can hear you now yes tell me
what's going on
okay i think uh nasima she
she seemed to knew sorry doc
uh younette i muted you because we're
having issues
hearing you so doc and a general
question
how about actually there's one from
steve that just popped up
how to treat macular degeneration
okay well mac your generation of course
can be
a diagnosis but there's all kinds of
things that go on with the eye
including osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing
the nerves squeezing the blood vessels
and all kinds of stuff
and um oftentimes doctors don't know
what to say why you're losing your
vision
a lot of pressure is going up in your
eye and they just say well you've got
back regeneration they just say that
stuff
okay and so this these people with max
regeneration
um our glaucoma are both uh are
cataracts now cataracts there's a
surgery far
um okay i only do one eye at a time i
wouldn't do both eyes at the same time
um but at any rate um when you have
degenerative generation
if that's correct um none of the bad
foods okay that could be caused by
inflammation eating fried foods
processed meats oils glutens wheat
browner adults and sugar
and then they need to take one healthy
brain and heart pack for 100 pounds of
body weight
you need to take the msm through those
twice a day per hundred pounds of body
weight in case you have obviously
approaches it's called squeezing
the optic nerve or the optic artery in
the optic vein and then
they need three eggs twice a day so they
can maintain
the white matter of the brain which is
75 by weight cholesterol
i need three eggs twice a day with soft
yolks fried eggs won't count and
and uh hard-boiled eggs won't count
and then i would also take the oculative
take go one of those twice
as two miles a month take the vision fx
take three of those twice as two vowels
a month
and then call us every couple of weeks
call us every time they go to the eye
doctor and get some kind of update and
what's going on with the eye
and we'll see if things are progressing
if they're staying the same or getting
worse
but maximizing absorption is essential
if you're going to spend the money for
all these supplements you want to make
sure you're absorbing them all
so got to get rid of the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat bread rhinos and no
sugar
okay let's try a couple more here if we
keep funneling around like this
i'm just going to ask that we call it a
day
sorry doc of the technical issues here
but we'll keep going
i just want to remind everyone get your
good food bad food list by going to
ask doc live dot com you can contact us
through their email us through there and
when you're ordering
if you're an existing customer or
distributor please circle back with the
person who sent you
replays of the show are available on
ask.live.com
do invite others we want to grow this
we're
expanding our army and looking for more
and more people
so doc a general question now um
how about ms what what's the general
protocol for ms
okay ms multiple sclerosis parkinson's
disease als lou gehrig's disease
they're all the same disease okay it's
just they affect different parts of the
brain
more severely so you get different
symptoms so they gave them different
names okay
so when people have all those different
problems they need to get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat bread
right now so sugar
you need to take three eggs twice a day
per hundred pounds of body weight
hard-boiled eggs won't count fridays
cause cancer soft yolks soft boiled soft
poached soft soft scrambling butter
then they need to have extend two health
abandoned heart packs per month
they also need to get the de-stress
capsules through those twice a day
the ultimate niacin plus one of those
twice a day the
uh let's see here i would also uh throw
in
the fucoid z through those twice as two
vowels a month
and then um i would also throw in
the um and see i said few coin z
i would i would throw in the um
uh let's just go with that
let's just go with that okay and see
what benefit we get here wonderful
thank you doc we do have a person
with a raised hand sharon please unmute
yourself
and be available by video
yes thank you hello doc
yeah hi listen oh it's such a pleasure
to get to meet you
you're you're just awesome oh you're
very kind how can we help you today
okay i'm i'm 68 i'm a retired x-ray
technologist i'm 5'3 145 pounds
i do have spider veins and white hair
i've been on your program for about a
year now
with the minerals and a healthy body
start pack
my question is i've developed tinnitus
tinnitus is caused by what uh
osteoporosis of the skull
yeah you get an a plus exactly and of
course it's squeezing the auditory
branch of the adrenal nerve
and so you you have your abs you have an
absorption problem so
a lot of people say well i'm not taking
any gluten well do you cook food for
your husband or your kids your grandkids
well yeah i cook their meals
yeah are they getting gluten yeah well
you're getting cross-contaminated in the
laundry and the food preparation
surfaces
and so forth and that's why you're not
getting the maximum benefit
okay so everybody's either got to move
out of the house or you move out of the
house
or they got to change their diet i'm
serious otherwise you're not going to
get the benefit here
okay right this is life and death stuff
um usually within two to three months
the varicose veins and hemorrhoids
should go away the hair color should
start coming back in your hair
but if you're not having those things
happening
you're still getting gluten from
somewhere and usually it's because
you're being kind and you're cooking
everybody else's meals
so and you know you're throwing flour
you know on something or whatever you
got to stop it
okay and so um you know hose them down
before they come in the house
don't let them in the house out hosing
them down in the front yard
and so again i gotta get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no gluten so we brought
ourselves to sugar
145 pounds i would take two healthy
abandoned heart packs per month
for those things twice a day and um
let's see here i said the msm take three
of those twice a day because you got
veins of main problems here and you got
osteoporosis of the skull
and so there's a lot of things happening
inside you you don't know what's going
on you may only have 10 liver function
okay and so because the same things that
are causing the tinnitus in the ears
which is very
you're very aware of that you can also
be getting problems in your liver and
your kidneys
your heart um your thyroid glands and so
forth
so wouldn't hurt to throw in some fucoid
z capsules you can take three of those
twice a day
and uh let's go in that direction okay
okay thank you so much
okay dear god bless you
all right dr wallach thank you so much
dr wallace kathy has a question
in regards to sugars
so she took your advice and got off all
the bad sugars especially sugar
and she recently ordered the tangy
tangerine
and we went through that we went through
that with her ready
oh i apologize that's when i was off all
right let's go to the next one
so natalie is 62 years old
um she's five foot nine
and 185 pounds
she recently gave a double red blood
cell
um donation and she does have a thyroid
issue recently as in last week
now she's in the hospital her blood
pressure is
212 over 180
her pulse is anywhere from 150 to 230.
doctors are thinking that it's because
the medications for her thyroid were not
being distributed
throughout her body can you share with
us a little bit about
what might be going on and what we can
do to do
to help her okay well she's not
absorbing properly okay
and she's got all kinds of things going
on here including
osteoporosis of the skull and so on
um so we need to get her off again all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens and
wheat bread around us so sugar
everybody in the household dog cat bird
fish spouse renter kids
grandkids so there's no
cross-contamination of the laundry and
the food preparation surfaces you know
the drill
okay and then at 185 pounds she needs
two healthy brain and heart pattern a
month to full dose everything twice a
day
she needs two bottles a month for the
msm she can take three with each meal
that's gonna support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes your bone
itself
i want her to take three of our ocean's
gold capsules twice a day that's two
bottles a month for her thyroid
i wanted to take three of our fucoid z
capsules twice a day that's two bottles
a month
uh that's for her thyroid uh because the
trace minerals that come in those two
puffs come from two different oceans
so we're dealing with two different
oceans here because she has high blood
pressure
um she needs to be taken the
ultimate daily classic tablets that will
support healthy blood pressure and
healthy blood flows or blocked arteries
okay and um
let's see here that also help her kidney
function
and i think
uh we've covered the territory here okay
oh she should also give up cruciferous
vegetables cabbage broccoli chopped
flour brown sprouts and kale because
they
interfere with thyroid function also
all right thank you dr wallach um
next question is coming from robin and
she writes in
my mother's nursing home is asking me to
reduce the amount of
supplements i'm providing currently mom
is taking about 25 pills per day
and she's not been eating she was doing
super good dr walik
um what she is on right now is the
on-the-go pack
msm ultimate daily classic bio-calcium
synaptic niacin kilobiotic
de-stress d3 selenium
and all of them are products and
now this she's had a history of dementia
she was doing fabulously and regaining
her
her memory stop okay stop stop stop do
we know if she's getting gluten you know
pancakes and waffles
and spaghetti and stuff like that and
oatmeal at this her daughter has
well her daughter has told him she has
to be on a gluten-free diet
whether they're going by that or not we
do not know
okay the odds are they're not and so um
i would get a hair analysis on this gal
this this woman okay we need a hair
analysis on her
and we'll find out whether she's
absorbing we'll find out if she's got
toxic metals
we'll find out a lot of stuff by hearing
analysis because
the doctors there and the nurses and
caregivers are guessing well we think
this
well what tests do they do to come up
with that idea okay
um maybe they're just giving her more
pancakes for breakfast
or they switched from potatoes at
dinnertime
to um spaghetti you know who knows
uh and so we need to find out what's
going on here
uh because if she's doing great and then
suddenly now she's not doing great
um and maybe she's gonna have to go to a
different nursing home if they're
telling you to stop giving her
supplements
okay this is crazy
right absolutely so they're basically
they just wanted to reduce the
supplements well they don't know why
so okay maybe she needs triple the
supplements you know who knows i mean
oh well you know we're not into
supplements so let's just reduce your
supplements
no i think it's more i think it's more
out of convenience for them dr wallach
yeah we don't have to sit there and
count up pills for her every day
right all right nasima has another
question
yep uh hi i'm on doc it's a question
from a client hi
in general again what are the effects
of excessive alcohol
the alcohol choice being wine or a
gluten-free alcohol when a person
is on medications taking supplements
and diagnosed with cancer
well it depends on what they want to
accomplish
if they're stage four cancer and the
doctors have only given them a couple of
months to live
i'd let them drink all the wine they
wanted okay
if they're just diagnosed with cancer
and they're the beginnings of their
treatments and everything
um you know they need to restrict
alcohol to maybe one glass of wine a day
kind of thing
um instead of a glass wine with each
meal you know you got to be reasonable
here if you want to have your body
do what it needs to do and of course
take the supplements and so on
so um these are common sense
answers to questions
um and there's many reasons why people
ask those questions maybe they don't
maybe they don't want to go to the store
and buy the wine and bring them to mine
who knows okay but uh
a glass of red wine once a day
if somebody even has 25 percent of their
liver that's okay
but you have to take the 90 cents of
nutrients so the body can defend itself
and function and maintain repair itself
uh a bottle of wine three times a day is
not good
right right thank you doc and
um you know if someone has the issue
with
alcohol taking in excessively it's
because of nutrition deficiency
that's right pika pika yeah pica they
have cravings
and alcohol will subdue the cravings a
little bit because it acts kind of like
anesthetic it actually
causes everything to quiet down go to
sleep and everything and so you're not
feeling that gosh i just have to eat
every three seconds
okay that's why people get addicted to
alcohol because it does help them
relieve some symptoms they want to get
rid of they say oh well now i'm addicted
to the alcohol
okay well get on the nutrients
and slowly slowly try to reduce the
amount of alcohol without causing
negative um withdrawal symptoms
thank you doc right back at you rebecca
thank you nasima so dr wallach janna has
a question about her husband
he is 69 years old 5 foot 7
181 pounds and he falls asleep
all the time especially after eating but
anytime that he's just sitting still
like in a chair
he falls asleep what is causing us and
what can be done
okay um this is actually
caused by what's what's called reactive
hypoglycemia
okay when you eat your body releases a
lot of insulin knocks your blood sugar
down you get sleepy
it's very common in middle ages of
seniors okay
it's one of those things where
this goes back to the beginning of time
this is nothing new
okay and so when people have these
issues they need to take more
supplements more minerals and they need
to eat more protein and less
carbohydrates
okay
so then as far as supplements doctor
wallach
okay well in this case i would give this
guy about two healthy brain heart packs
per month
bulldoze everything twice a day i'd get
them on two bottles a month of the
sweeties and take three of those twice
they might want to get three bottles and
for a while and give them three
of the sweeties with each meal okay
that's going to help
modulate and moderate the amount of
insulin pain raises that reduced
um and
um you know again this goes back to the
beginning of time this is nothing new
but it is a
deficiency that causes the body to keep
releasing more and more
insulin which drops the blood sugar
which caused them to go to sleep
all right thank you so much so now
dr wallace let's get back to um
people that are going out and exercising
we've got somebody that
they said they're well they're 47 years
old
uh 123 pounds
at five foot six and she used to be an
avid runner
she says now when she goes out and runs
she gets
extreme pain in her calves and her
thighs and the muscles she said
sometimes it feels like it's in the
bones themselves but not so much in the
joints
it's a back problem a back problem
yeah she's got peripheral neuropathy
okay she's got sciatica
okay and so has has this guy shrunk a
little bit
you know half inch or so so the
vertebrae are getting closer to smashing
those sciatic nerves
it's just like when somebody has
numbness and tingling in their feet and
toes and hammer toes and everything
they'll go to a foot doctor and they'll
do surgery and all that kind of stuff
but there's really a back problem
causing sciatica peripheral neuropathies
in the feet same thing when your skull
is squeezing your spinal cord coming out
of the back your skull
causing what doctors will call you have
carpal tunnel syndrome because your
hands are going to sleep you have
trigger finger
no it's a neck problem because the skull
is squeezing out
the spinal cord is coming out of the
back of the skull okay these are called
peripheral neuropathies
okay all right thank you so much dr
wallach
and we have um
dominic has a question about weight
and they're on a 100 1500 calorie diet
they did lose 12 pounds in the first
month and the next pound
gained it back um and
currently they're doing 20 flights to
stairs with no significant loss
and you know trying to cut out the
sugary fruits
but haven't been able to well here's
what they need to do start out with one
meal
a day our keto caramel bar
the shakes are gone so just use a bar
one meal a day doesn't have to be the
same meal every day
we have strawberry chocolate though dog
well we have strawberry chocolate but
it's not a keto
shake it is we now have a keto shake so
okay um one meal a day and after a month
or two
go to maybe two meals a day a keto meal
and see you can use a half a pound of
two pounds a day
but they got to take the 90 essential
nutrients because the behavior of pica
cravings and eating and eating and
eating and eating you just ate a 5 000
calorie meal ralph why are you still
eating i don't know i'm just still
hungry
well that's because you know grandma you
say you got a hole in your leg you know
you just keep eating and eating eating
you've got a hole in your leg that's why
you're gaining all this weight because
you keep eating
eating because you got a hole in your
leg the food just goes in and keeps
piling up in your leg
no that's because you're minerally
deficient and you have this craving
called pica p-i-c-a
and again this is where these books from
the cds and things come in
really really really people have to
go in this direction educate themselves
and not depend totally on a doctor 100
now if you get run over by a car and
you're bleeding internally you got to go
to the emergency room no
you know there's certain common sense
things here
but if you've been feeling around with
the doctor and losing and gaining and
losing and gaining
your blood sugar is up and down and up
and down your blood pressure is up and
down well let's try this drug let's try
that drug
the doctor says stuff like this he don't
know what he's doing
it's time for you to kind of take over
and begin to do stuff yourself here
um and with very factual information the
other references so you can look it up
if you want to go to the original
research
if you want to do that but um you know
we've been doing this a long time
for 73 years and so we have a little
handle on this
just a little bit just a little bit so
you know a lot of people think that you
have to eat lots of vegetables in order
to lose weight and
like dominic is suffering with with
hypothyroidism which
the cruciferous vegetables you don't
want in your diet
so it's truly it's mineral deficiencies
isn't it dr wallach
yes yeah it's it's mineral deficiencies
and of course
you get these side effects and then you
take something like
marijuana or you take opioids or you
take a drug
it makes you feel better oh my god i
love my doctor i'm going to leave
everything in my bowl to my doctor
okay well they're managing your symptoms
they're not getting rid of the disease
well yeah i've been on these drugs for
12 years
okay try going without those drugs oh i
can't go without those drugs i tried and
just you know within three weeks all my
symptoms came back
well that means the doctor is just
managing your symptoms and
milking you like a dairy cow
yeah duct tape doesn't fix everything
does it nope
let's go to the underlying cause folks
well again
i just want to thank everybody for
joining us with the ask doc
live program here where we have the
one and only dr joel wallick
who not only has been treating
humans for the last 50 years
but started out treating animals
animals can't tell you what's going on
folks
and through all of his research through
all the autopsies and comparing
millions of data points he has figured
it out
and because of the goodness of his heart
he's here to share that information with
us and it's been published many many
times
over and over so it's not just words
it's actual information
research proven time
and time again so again if somebody
invited you to this
program get back with them
tell them hey dr wallach was mentioning
this
about this person i have those same
symptoms as well
i need to find out what protocol is best
for me
you can then go to askdoclive.com
you can pull up the recording of the
program
and listen to exactly what dr wallach
has shared
all of the products that are shared
there can be found
at the askdoclive.com store
including dr wallach's books that are
just so valuable dr wallach
thank you so much for bringing all of
this information to us
we greatly appreciate you and the time
that you're taking
well thank you rebecca thank you ruth
ellen thank you nasima
thank you john t thank you team
and we'll see you next week yes on
behalf of the whole entire team
everybody
see you next friday same place same time
have a great one
and bye for now stay away from gluten
yeah stay away from gluten bye bye dr
wallach